1300 c'est le nombre d'élèves
d'Indre-et-Loire inscrit au dispositif
vacances apprenantes scolarisée en
primaire ou au collège pour la rentrée
ils se rendent à l'école pendant une
semaine pour suivre du soutien scolaire
le matin et faire du sport l'après-midi
des stages de la réussite pour les
occuper et pour leur permettre d'être
bien préparé pour septembre Benjamin
Vatel les a suivis au collège de l'arche
du Lude a Joué-lès-Tours
ce matin c'était court de français dans
la classe de Madame l'automne avec un
groupe réduit d'une dizaine d'élèves le
dispositif vacances apprenantes comprend
les stages de réussite pour revoir des
notions d'histoire de français ou de
mathématiques et l'après-midi est
consacrée à des activités sportives ou
culturelles
[Rires]
refais déconner on revoit des
connaissances là des questions de
grammaire un travail d'écriture ce matin
avec les troisièmes on a revu des
notions grammaire également qui sont
essentielles pour le brevet donc on
revoit de manière plus ludique des
choses qu'on va voir cette année ou
qu'ils ont vu l'anniversaire la plupart
des élèves sont volontaires pour
participer à ces stages
par exemple là on devait répondre à la
question les fourmis noir et on devait
terminer la terminaison et tout à
l'heure on a joué on a fait déjà des
anagrammes c'est aussi un moyen pour eux
de découvrir leur professeur autrement
dans un cadre moins strict
ils sont vu qu'on est beaucoup plus bah
c'est plus
carré faut toujours dans le silence là
on peut parler on peut chuchoter c'est
plus cool on va dire
dispositif existe depuis longtemps mais
il se développe de plus en plus 1300
élèves du département sont concernés
cette année c'est le double de l'an
dernier ça leur permet de découvrir des
lieux de prendre confiance et puis mais
pour la grande majorité d'entre eux ce
qu'ils aiment c'est c'est de faire de
nouvelles activités de travailler
différemment en fait c'est il le dit
souvent il a ils aiment faire du
français de manière plus ludique après
les cours les élèves sont partis en vélo
avec leur professeur pour visiter les
grottes pétrifiantes donc on va faire le
tour du il y a un petit chemin qui fait
le tour là pareil vous restez bien
derrière moi un moyen de retrouver le
collège en douceur avant la rentrée
officielle lundi prochain